hi this is presh tallaker let's learn
how to multiply numbers that are close
to 100 in your head
let's do 97 times 96 there are three
steps to the process
the first step is to write down the
difference from 100 97 is 3 less than
196 is 4 less
the second step is to cross subtract 97
minus 4 is 93
you'll notice that if you cross subtract
the other way it's the same answer
the final step is to cross multiply
three times four is twelve and that's
our answer nine thousand three hundred
and twelve
let's do another example ninety-eight
times ninety-three
we first take the difference from a
hundred of each number
then we cross subtract
and finally we cross multiply
and then we get our answer
9114
we can also do this for numbers that are
in the 80s it's exactly the same steps
we take the difference from 100 we cross
subtract
and then finally we cross multiply
the same
similar process will work if the two
numbers are above a hundred
you take the difference from a hundred
but now the only difference is we will
cross add a hundred and seven plus four
is a hundred and eleven we still cross
multiply and that's our answer
here's a quick proof of why this works
in general our multiplication problems
have been a hundred minus x times a
hundred minus y
we can write it in this form 100 minus x
minus y is cross subtract and the xy is
the cross multiply please subscribe to
my channel
you can support me on patreon
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
on twitter at preshtalwalkar
and you can get my books and amazon